the graph of the function G is shown  below what is the input value for which  G of X is equal to negative 2 so what  they do over here is along the x-axis  these are the inputs and then the graph  shows us what's the output so when X is  equal to 7  G of 7 we see here is 1 if x equals 9 G  of 9 here is 2 if x equals 6 G of 6 is  equal to the y-coordinate at this point  is equal to 0 so what is the input value  for which G of X is equal to negative 2  well this graph right over here this is  y equals G of X so G of X equaling  negative 2 means Y is equal to negative  2 and so when does y equal negative 2  well when does y equal negative 2 it  looks like that happens right at this  point and that happens when you input  negative 9 into G G of negative 9 is  negative 2 so this is going to be  negative 9 and we're done